but first the latest on our top story
the goodwill of the Olympic Games
appears to be thawing relations between
North and South Korea not the North's
leader Kim jong-un invited South Korea's
president to Pyongyang for a summit in
hopes of easing tensions between the
rival nations the message was delivered
by Kim's sister today just hours after
the Winter Games opened in South Korea
she travelled to the south as part of
the North's delegation to the Olympics
Ben Tracy is in the Olympic city of
Pyeongchang
Ben good morning good morning South
Korean president moon jae-in has said
that he wants these to be the peace
Olympics and a turning point for
relations here on the Korean Peninsula
and it looks like he may be getting his
wish
president moon hosted Kim jong-un's
sister kim yo-jong today at the blue
house in seoul during that meeting she
told moon that Kim Jong moon wants him
to visit the North Korean capital at the
earliest date possible for what would be
the third inter-korean summit since the
Korean War now at the opening ceremony
of the Winter Olympics Friday night here
in Pyeongchang moon and Kim shook hands
in what was deemed a historic moment US
vice president Mike Pence was sitting in
a row in front of her but the two never
spoke during the ceremony athletes from
North and South Korea marched together
under a unified flag symbolizing their
hope for a more peaceful future now
president moon has not officially
accepted this invitation to go to North
Korea but he apparently told Kim Jong
Un's sister they should create the
conditions that would make that possible
in the future this could complicate the
Trump administration's plan of using
sanctions to try to isolate North Korea
and convince it to give up its nuclear
weapons program
Alex Ben Tracy at the Winter Olympics in
South Korea thanks Ben